okay so one division has left a lot of
people
with a lot of questions no one knows
what's going on in west view
what's happening with the twins no not
them you dirty bad boy
who's controlling wonder how vision is
alive and so on
if you're one of those people who's
showing visible confusion
then this is the video for you
throughout it we're going to be giving
our best theories based on the comics
whilst also answering what we know about
the series so far
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't seen up to
episode three then i recommend that you
reset right now
if you enjoy the video then it would be
swell if you hit the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns like this each
and every day
without the way i'm your host paul
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
now let's get into the video okay so the
biggest question hanging over the series
is where
exactly is wonder and what's going on in
west view
episode 3 actually gave us a big reveal
in its ending
and we discovered that the town was
indeed a real location
that had been turned into the reality
that we see wonder and vision living in
i've read theories that this might just
be above hologram
but the fact that the objects are
tangible and from the outside everything
seems okay
makes me believe that the technology
isn't being used here
looking at the promotional images for
episode 4 it's only upon entering it
that things seem to change
whereas with bath you can see it from no
matter where you look at it
there was also a clip released of the
beekeeper character crawling through the
membrane
and if you look closely at his clothing
you'll see that it only transforms upon
passing through the invisible barrier
therefore we can confirm that west's
view seems okay
and it's only when you enter that things
start to get worse than 2020
this idea of it seeming okay from the
outside and being messed up within
of course carries over to the plot of
the show itself but we'll discuss that
later in the video
now westview itself has some pretty
significant things in the name
that make it the perfect location for a
show like this
not only do the initials w and v also
stand for wonder and vision
but the name itself actually has tv in
the middle
wowzer it also seems like a suburban
town in the middle of nowhere
and i actually think that one of the
latest mcu movies highlights to us
exactly what wonder might be doing now
i'm someone who habitually always has
the mcu
on one tv in the house at all times i've
binged the movies
more than i'd like to admit but it was
only with the context of this show that
i noticed something different
you might remember that avengers end
game ends with steve rogers
traveling back to an alternate 1950s to
be with the one that you lost
i'm not crying i'm not crying this is
also very similar to wanda
who traveled to a 1950s reality in order
to be with the person she loved
more than anything in the world clearly
there's parallels between the pair
and i personally believe that when old
joe biden steve showed up at the end
that the avengers eventually managed to
pry open the truth from him
and this then inspired wander to try
something similar
as much as the radio messages from sword
make it seem like she's the one being
manipulated
the series itself does show that she is
in control
when the beekeeper arrives she easily
rewinds time
and then when vision starts to question
things she too snaps him out of it
completely derailing his train of
thought the way she threw moniker out of
the reality was nothing short of
spellbinding
and it's clear that she's been able to
bend and manipulate things at will
all the people in the show seem to be
trapped there and dr nielsen did discuss
how difficult it is to get away
herb nelly let it slip that they were
trapped i think
and mrs hart in episode 1 was almost on
the verge of tears trying to save her
husband
whilst remaining in character however
that doesn't mean that she's not being
used
and so far the show has laid out several
clues to us that the nefarious forces in
this reality
are aiming to manipulate her to their
own ends now though we don't know this
for definite
it seems like all the signs there are
pointing towards the people there being
after her children
and the show looks like it has multiple
villains the first of them
is of course agnes yes she's buddy she's
not your friend
she's a bad woman now i've already made
a video about who i think she really is
which goes into this theory and the
evidence in more detail
but the long and short of it is that
she's likely agatha harkness
agatha has sort of gone back and forth
over being a villain
throughout the decades but she has
helped wanda to enhance her powers
it is possible that in researching ways
to get her peggy carter ending
that she crossed paths with the figure
and she helped her to build this
dimension
in the comics agatha also went to wander
and vision when the pair had twins
and they just so happened to have the
names billy and tommy
it was revealed that the pair were
actually carrying the souls of demons
and i believe that agnes has ulterior
motives for aiding wonder
and that she's actually been warping the
reality in order to subliminally hint to
scarlet witch
that she needs to have kids in episode 1
vision's boss mr hart
nelly had a heart attack when asking why
the pair didn't have any kids
the second episode was centered around
an event for the children
and it all seemed to be driving home the
idea that wonder had to have them
we know from the promo of episode 4 that
agnes calls herself anti-agnes
and if you cast your mind back to the
animated intro of episode 2
you may have noticed a sign in the
supermarket that said auntie a's
so clearly she's been pushing the idea
that they should have children
and going off the source material she
may want to steal them so that she can
serve them up to her masters
now it's also possible that agnes is in
league with hydra
or someone worse no not you dominic
cummings now exploring the first option
the organization have popped up at
numerous points in the commercials
and even so far back as winter soldier
they were creating
young and powerful people so that they
could take over the world
they could also be after the infinity
stones too as the snap showed everyone
just how powerful they were we know from
the mind stone in visions head that
wonder can
indeed create them and if you watch the
commercials again with this in mind
they could also be subliminally hinting
to her and the audience that she needs
to rebuild them
the first commercial had a red flashing
light and typically red is associated
with the reality stone
the second commercial centered around a
watch which could be hinting towards the
time stone
and the third episode had a blue box
which may have been the tesseract
that could be reaching and it's not
something i've dug my heels on just yet
but obviously my commercial 4 will have
more of an idea
now i believe that they made an alliance
with agnes to get her to make wonder
create the children and infinity stones
and from here they'll try and rise to
power we know from the falcon and winter
soldier first looks that hydra are
indeed in the series
due to the yellow and green jumpsuits
that were showcased in the first trailer
and thus it makes sense that they're
back on the rise now agnes could also be
in league with a much darker and
sinister figure
and that is mephisto she's referred to
her husband ralph
quite a lot but so far in the series we
haven't actually seen him
or so we think now the name ralph
actually means
wolf and it is possible that satan
himself is shape-shifted into certain
animals in order to keep a close eye on
things
in episode 2 we saw agnes carrying
around a rabbit
and in episode 3 the stork made an
appearance
the latter was notable because it's the
one thing so far that wonder hasn't been
able to control in the reality
and it seems like something else is
indeed going on with it
agnes also mentioned in episode 1 that
her wedding anniversary was june 2nd
and this was actually the day that the
first salem witch trials took place
could this mean that on the date the
trial started she pledged her undying
love to lucifer in order to be kept safe
from home
well i think so and it would also tie in
with the demon souls storyline which the
show has been influenced by
the series is also laced with satanic
imagery and the idea
of 666 there was of course the upside
down cross that was also a sword symbol
the tentacles on the hydra logo appear
to have 666 in them
hexagons also pop up at several points
in the credits and these have six sides
which
if you look closely enough you'll see
that it's a reach yep it's it's another
reach
now another big question that people
likely have is how is vision alive
well going back to the vision and
scholar which graphic novel
in that book the grim reaper makes a big
appearance he has the ability to bring
people back from the dead
and mephisto and agnes could have gone
to him for help so that he could bring
back the one thing that wanda loved to
keep her tied to this reality
so they could steal her kids his helmet
did appear in the opening of episode 1
and i don't think that this would have
been included if it had no significance
if we look at agnes's pendant there also
appears to be three figures
and the one in the middle looks like it
could be the classic depiction of the
grim reaper holding a side above its
head
so if our theory is right then the three
figures could represent her
death and the devil all who've made an
allegiance together
now as for who billy and tommy actually
are as mentioned earlier they were demon
soul babies
that were meant to usher in generations
of darkness that make
2020 look like 1999.
was was that a good joke i don't know i
was 11.
anyway the point is that they have a
precedence in the comics to be a certain
way however billy and tommy is also the
name of the children that wander and
vision had after that saga
and they went on to become the young
avengers wiccan in speed
i believe that the story for both might
be combined and
after saving the babies instead of them
perishing they'll go on to become the
two mutants that marvel maniacs
absolutely love
and lastly what is going on with
geraldine
or rather monika well after being tossed
out of the reality
she landed at the sword facility and we
know from the promo shots of episode 4
that she's likely investigating the
bubble
if our theory about hydra is correct
then it makes sense that sword would be
used instead of shield
as we already know that hydra
infiltrated their organization from the
winter soldier
alongside her is jimmy wu played by
randall park
who you may remember from ant-man and
the wasp the last time we saw him he was
keeping a close eye on scott
to make sure he didn't break the sokovia
records and also learning
some delightful magic tricks wander is
someone who also did that
not just the magic tricks but but broke
the sokovia records
so it could be possible that after the
blip he was assigned to her
and then she went into the bubble
dimension which forced him to call in
the big guns
in the comics moniker is a person known
as photon who was blessed with
incredible gifts
and she is likely going to get these
powers at some point in the show
it's even possible that after being
tossed through the membrane that she's
picked them up
but for now we're gonna have to wait
until friday to find out
anyway that's our big theories and all
the answers we have so far
going off what clues have been left i'd
obviously love to hear your
thoughts and whether you agree or not so
make sure you drop them in the comments
section below
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
store on the 30th of january
in which we're giving away three copies
of the hobbit and lord of the rings 4k
box sets to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the theories
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
episode 3
which will be linked on screen right now
we picked about the entire piece
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want more one division
or if you're just bored because this
lockdown's been never ending
in the uk at least anyway without the
way thank you for sticking through the
video
i mean paul you've been the best and
i'll see you next time you take care
a piece